a part two about the last episode
of the handmaid's tale 5 review um so
when i first saw the screener for the
episode i was
uh shocked at that scene with luke and
june but i had to tiptoe
about how i was gonna approach it
because i had no one to talk to about
the scene with and i was worried and
thought maybe that
it was a case like game of thrones if
you've seen it
obviously you've seen game of thrones
but where there's a scene in later
seasons where jaime
clearly raped cersei right and then the
writers came out and said they didn't
mean for it to come off that way and
that could be that can happen a lot
where
the writers write something one way and
the director directs a different way and
it comes off the way
it wasn't meant to be and i was hoping
that
maybe that was the case here right that
okay that this was a case of the writers
didn't mean for it to come off like rape
but it was directed that way
clearly is rape the scene with uh luke
and june
and i wanted to be cautious about how i
handled that and now i'm giving you my
honest
take after seeing interviews and
there is a post on reddit you can see
where there's uh i forget the name of
the podcast
um that interviewed the writer of this
episode and they talked about this scene
and she says that they
wrote it that they wanted to be as
realistic as possible
right and that in this quote she's
basically saying that
because june is this victim been through
so much abuse
that and they're saying in this episode
that there's all this f
sex life they all have that there would
be moments where
even consent's not clear for her so
basically confirming that yeah it was
written that way that it was rape and
that
she felt as the writer that it was the
only honest genuine way to do it and
anything else would feel fake
i can agree with that statement but i
think that's super problematic because
you know it's still a tv show so june
has always been in the position of
someone we root for she's we see the
lens of the show through
um i like june the survivor not the
abuser
and it scares me because
having even seen the next episode no
spoilers but you know you clearly see
in trailers that it's that's an
episode's called you know
testimony right she's gonna testify so
it's hard to watch
her testify about being raped when we
just saw a scene before of her raping
somebody
so why it worries me
is because it just feels like that's
such a big decision by the writers to
make
that okay we're going to go to that and
show what we think would really happen
and you can have that decision in any
show in any scene but
it's also has huge repercussions because
you can already see by the reaction on
reddit like
that it's turning so many people off and
out of june and that scares me because
it's turning me off to june you know i'm
always team june and i've always again
this journey started through her story
and
it's gonna be a tough sell for me i
think a lot of people can relate to this
i'm wondering how you all feel
that now we're gonna be
seeing this story still through june's
lens june's lens but
you know she's a rapist so am i supposed
to
be okay with that so
i don't know if i am crazy about the
decision for them to add
that scene especially because we just
had a great scene before that where
she's
you know having this big moment with
serena we're getting this huge path we
all waited for
to just turn her now into a serena and
then she
even was talking about the parallels
that people are seeing which i
completely missed on
where you're seeing the perils between
her and serena and that narration
and um that
really upsets me and i know
i see that comment that says june's been
problematic from the beginning but she
hasn't raped anybody okay this
is a different level this is this is
something where
i don't think it ever works and shows
have done this before where like you do
something so bad they can't come from i
think the top of my head is actually
uh jack bauer in 24 and he kills like a
good guy in one season and the show
never recovered from that because then
at the moment you lost the audience on
your main person it's like the only
character it's really hard to pull this
off with
and and like that comment i think the
show is illustrating the abuse can
become abusers it is
it totally is um i'm just saying in show
terms this is worrisome for how
it's gonna affect our our view of our
person we root for because
it's so realistic and accurate but it's
something that's gonna have huge you
know
consequences because i think it turns a
lot of people off it's it's a heavy-duty
thing and it's a heavy decision to make
june
do something really really unlikable and
bad and um
i don't know it's it's it's ad skiing a
lot
uh but
i it brings my score down for the
episode honestly like it really actually
pisses me off
i don't think it's the right choice but
i don't even know what to say anymore
it's such a it's such a touchy thing
but all i know is that it's if we look
at it basically right and you look at
the landscape of tv shows and you look
at
protagonists main characters then they
get gray which is totally normal we've
seen this
that's fine but this is like going the
other level this is like villainizing
them
and like i said because they made a
decision to parallel
to serena in the episode we're supposed
to be happy that she's like
putting down serena i i don't know
then it's like then who are we gonna
attach to for the rest of this show
that's really tough to paul for
everybody's pretty bad
everybody so it's like i don't know
that's my thoughts and though i don't
want to think like you guys thought i
was ignorant not
acknowledging what happened at scene i
was just kind of tipping my toes with it
and trying to see maybe it was that
situation where
it was conveyed wrong but no yeah it's
clearly
luke getting raped and it really i don't
i can't process it because it's like i
can't believe
june you know i can believe jun would do
that in the situation she's been in but
i'm i'm just shocked the show's made
that choice to go that way because
that's
that's a lot that's a lot to take in for
june the character
you know so we'll see that's my live
thoughts uh on that praise be
still of the show uh but yeah i would
say i'll adjust my score now to like
an eight that's big that's big
uh but yeah thanks for all your support
guys and enjoy it i wish i was still
wearing the robe i'm not
uh and again let's all just be civil and
nice to each other you know
it's touchy subjects but everyone's
doing their best
have a great great day